Et c'est pour ça que compte tenu de
l'exposé de 9h qu'on vient de vous faire
et si on se réfère à l'annexe 2 de ce
document, notre conclusion est que
Nintendo et Sega ben les deux se valent.
Allez s'il vous plaît laissez-moi
partir, je dirai rien. Voilà. Ben je
pense qu'on peut conclure ça en disant
que la guerre des consoles bel et bien
fini
hein. Et les dessins animés ? Oh parce
que les dessins animés Mario et Sonic,
bon Mario ça passait mais Sonic.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1 2 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Cut à tous, nouvelle heure sujet et on
va repartir vers les années 80.
Souvenez-vous, on avait déjà parlé de
dessins animés tirés de jeux vidéos. On
avait parlé de Street Fighter, du film
Mortal Kombat, de Zelda, mais il y en a
plein d'autres. Et au passage, il y
avait même des dessins animés tiré de
jeux de rôle comme la série Donjon et
Dragon. Alors, c'est un peu hors sujet
certes, mais j'en parle vite fait parce
que la série m'avait marqué. L'épisode 1
commence donc direct par des gens en
costume qui escaladent d'une montagne.
OK, alors c'est qui ces mecs ? Ils sont
où ? Ils font quoi ? Pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sont déguisés comme ça ? Et
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont une licorne
qui miole
? Effectivement, si cette série était un
jeu de rôle, alors le MJ n'en avait rien
à branler. Tu voulais du scénario ? Mate
le générique, connard. Donc,
visiblement, un groupe de potes faisait
un train fantôme nommé Donjon et Dragon
quand soudainement le train les aspire à
l'intérieur du monde de Donjon et
Dragon. Et heureusement qu'ils étaient
pas dans une attraction de fistyland.
Et donc l'équipe est composée d'un
chevalier, d'un archer, d'un barbare,
d'un magicien, d'une voleuse classique
et
d'une acrobate acrobate. Ouais, vous
êtes des bons athlètes hein vous
les les femmes. Donc le vieux sage qui
s'appelle le maître du donjon en VO leur
donne une arme magique à chacun et
n'accepte de les aider à rentrer chez
eux que si la bande lui obéit pour
vaincre le méchant, le terrible
dégueulasse, le
dégueulasse. Il s'appelle vengeur mais
il est dégueulasse. Mais on peut pas
juste attraper le vieux et le torturer
jusqu'à ce qu'il accepte de nous
renvoyer chez nous ? Non. Et pourquoi ?
Parce que tu es con. Voilà pourquoi. Du
coup, à peine être arrivé dans ce monde,
le groupe d'enfants tombe sur Tiamat, un
espèce d'énorme dragon à cinq têtes.
Alors, dans le monde de Donjon et
Dragon, j'explique, Tiamat, c'est à peu
près le pire truc sur lequel tu peux
tomber. Ils sont là depuis 25
secondes. Le MJ est un connard. C'est
bon, j'ai fini de remplir ma fiche et
là, il y a un énorme dragon qui vous
fonce dessus. Je fais mes de
dégâts. Tu es mort. Tu es mort. Tu es
morte.
Donc après avoir évité le premier
dragon, les gosses décident sur les
conseils du maître du donjon d'aller
voir Merlin l'enchanteur. Et c'est
Merlin, il connaît tout le monde. Ouais,
Merlin l'enchanteur carrément. Écoutez,
arrêtez de me critiquer hein, je sais ce
que je fais. Bon, Merlin l'enchanteur
vous dit d'aller voir un certain Dark
Vador. Tout ça pour trouver un moyen de
repartir chez eux. Mais Merlin était en
fait un imposteur qui se sert du
magicien pour faire une potion pour
libérer les dragons. Encore plein de
dragons et puis après, il y a des
dragons qui attaquent le village et puis
pour combattre tous les dragons et ben
ils utilisent notre dragon. Alors il y a
un dragon qui se bat contre notre dragon
dans le donjon et l'épisode 2 et il y a
encore un dragon et puis il y a des
dragons dans tous les épisodes et il y a
des donjons et il y a des dragons. Écrit
quoi sur mon livre ? Il y a écrit quoi ?
Mass Effect. Ouais. Bref, après c'est
presque comme toutes les séries de cette
époque. Les épisodes sont déconnectés
les uns des autres sans réelle
continuité. Ça peut se comprendre parce
que c'était assez fréquent que les
épisodes soient diffusés dans le
désordre. Et c'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui, c'était juste l'apéritif
parce qu'évidemment là on est là pour
parler de série tiré de jeux vidéo. Fin
80 aux États-Unis, la hype du jeu vidéo
est tellement forte depuis la sortie de
l'année que rapidement des gens pleines
passion se disent qu'il doit absolument
sortir des dessins animés sur le jeu
vidéo avec comme seul objectif de faire
plaisir aux enfants. C'est pour
l'argent. NBC commande donc une série
d'épisodes autour du jeu vidéo dans
laquel on trouve en vrac Captain N et
les séries Mario que ce soit Super Mario
Bros, Super Mario Bross 3 ou Super Mario
World. Il ne s'agit pas de la première
apparition de Mario puisque celle-ci
remonte à un obscur dessin animé donc
Kongque de 84 mais c'est la première
série dédiée à un jeu vidéo. En France,
nous aussi les dessins animés arrivent
quelques années plus tard à partir des
années 90. successivement donc sur
antenne 2 dans Bonjour Babar et
Télévisateur
2. Les deux frères plombiers héros pas
dans les jeux vidéo bizarre bizarre tout
paraît bizarre chez les plombiers quand
il répare les filles part dans les tri
bah c'est un peu la naissance du rap
français l'émission notamment était
assez connue pour ces parties live avec
les deux vrais acteurs qui jouaient
Mario et Luigi et qui étaient un petit
peu Faut pas que je la touche. Mon
surcil va sauter. [ __ ]
[Musique]
Gl. Alors, heureuse. Alors, le dessin
animé en lui-même, par contre, je vais
pas trop m'étendre dessus parce que sans
être exceptionnel, il est plutôt commun
et pas trop mal quand même. On retrouve
les bruitages placés au bon endroit. Il
y a les ennemis, il y a même des mini
passages qui font beaucoup penser au jeu
en lui-même. Et pourtant, Nintendo, vous
le savez, était spécialiste des
adaptations pourries comme princesse
Zelda qu'on avait déjà abordé il y a
très longtemps. Mais la dernière fois,
il y avait que peu d'épisodes. Or,
récemment, les épisodes ont été uploadés
sur YouTube, ce qui nous permet
d'apprécier la vraie valeur de ce dessin
animé.
Mais ça ne tient pas debout cette
histoire. Les belles jeunes filles sont
censées être sauvées par un jeune et
séduisant héros et non pas par une autre
belle jeune fille.
Je crois que c'était le bruit d'une
féministe qui vient d'exploser.
D'ailleurs, c'est sympa puisque la
version française nous permet
d'apprécier l'effort de traduction et
c'est cool hein. Par exemple, la
tripforce maintenant s'appelle diamant
des trois forces de la sagesse ou bien
le force 3 ou alors le tr forces. Tout
ça pour décrire visiblement un ballon à
l'hélium. Unant magique l'a attiré vers
le fond qui parle. Regarde ça. On dirait
qu'ils vont promener le chien là. Où est
le force 3 ? Je sais pas. Regarde au
plafond. C'est peut-être envolé après
notre pique-nique. Tu accepteras
peut-être de me Oh oh oh oh ! De quoi ?
De te quoi ? Je veux savoir. Et l'autre
série honteuse de Nintendo, le petit
sucret bien caché, c'est bel et bien
Captain N. Alors cette série est assez
introuvable en français en tout cas
concernant les deux premières saisons.
C'est pour ça donc on vous l'a
sous-titré. Bref, alors que le monde de
Vidé Hollande est au bord de la défaite
contre les forces de la terrible mama
Servela, méchante de métroïde. Wouh ! On
dirait la fusion entre un chewing-gum et
une [ __ ] Soudainement, l'espoir rené
quand le power glove décide d'appeler
Kevin à la rescous en l'aspirant à
travers son écran de télé. C'était un
dysfonctionnement classique des
téléviseurs dans les années 90.
D'ailleurs, au passage, c'est
typiquement le genre de série que tu
peux plus faire depuis l'arrivée
d'internet. Kevin était un garçon
ordinaire jusqu'au jour où il fut
inspiré dans l'internet pour évite des
aventures d'exceptionnelles.
Oh mon dieu, il y a du porno partout. Du
porno maman ?
Waouh, vous êtes dégueulasse. Bref, donc
dans les héros de vidéollande, on trouve
Kidarus, Simon Belbon qui vit dans
Castlvania. C'est pas genre il habite au
château de Dracula ou en Transylvanie.
Non non, il habite à Castlvania. C'est
comme si Nathan Drake il habitait à
Uncharted. Megaman qui ben c'est un peu
comme si un rasmet avait [ __ ] le mec
de la soupou et qui en français
d'ailleurs va faire plein de super jeux
de mots à base de méga vu que c'est
megga man. Il faut que l'on avance à
méga vitessus. Oh toi, je vais t'adorer.
J'aime beaucoup sa voix anglaise aussi.
[Musique]
D'ailleurs, j'ai un méga
cancer et la princesse Lana tirée du
jeu, j'ai un vagin et c'est ma seule
raison d'être ici. Et donc Kevin va
devoir sauver à lui seul tout le monde
de
vidéolande. Trop bien. J'ai pas encore
permis mais j'ai déjà un flingue.
[Musique]
Je ne sais pas. La dernière fois que je
l'ai vu, il était dans sa chambre, il
jouait à son Nintendo "Retrouvez mon
fils, s'il vous plaît." Bref, alors que
Kevin hésite à devenir le game master,
ben Mama Servela envoie ses sous-fifres
pour capturer Lana, c'est-à-dire Kingipo
de Punchout et le magicien aubergine de
Kidikarus. Oh, même les méchants, c'est
l'équipe B. La princesse Lana capturée
est donc ramenée sur le monde de
métroïd. Terrible planète des randoms
effet sonores.
Et pour les bruitages, c'est comme ça
dans à peu près toutes les scènes. OK,
là c'est la scène où l'armée
avance. OK. Et alors là, c'est la scène
super émouvante avec la princesse.
Bref, pendant ce temps-là, les héros se
trompent de Warp Zone et arrivrive dans
le monde de Donkey Kong où après
quelques péripéties, ils réussissent
finalement à s'enfuir grâce au pouvoir
de Kevin qui peut arrêter le temps. Rien
que ça. Sérieusement, il peut arrêter le
temps sans limite et à volonté. Et
comment ils vont justifier que la série
du coup se termine pas en un épisode ?
Et bref, donc Lana est libérée mais
alors que Kevin s'apprête à rentrer chez
lui pour retrouver son monde, on entend
sa mère lui demander de faire ses
devoirs et de sortir la
poubelle. Fuck you, je préfère rester là
et tirer sur des
trucs et ainsi de suite. Vous vous en
doutez, les épisodes n'ont pas de
continuité. Il va s'agir à chaque fois
d'une petite histoire et à chaque fois
les scénaristes vont déborder
d'imagination pour ruiner toutes les
licences possibles hein. Que ce soit les
boss dans Megan ou des méchant super
badas qui sont transformés en
Sérieusement lui c'est ça là. Bon alors
OK c'est pas la même époque mais quand
même quoi. Et puis si on nomme à Mar
Servela de Mtroïde pourquoi est-ce qu'il
y a pas Samus de métroïde aussi ?
Pourquoi tu mets random princesse numéro
43 là ? Allô ou tu vois avec toutes mes
explications, je pense que j'ai quand
même réussi à prouver que Nintendo ben
c'était un peu de la merde non ? De quoi
tu parles ? Ça fait 10 minutes que tu as
les yeux dans le vide et puis que tu dis
plus rien. Et puis Sonic, c'était pas
mieux. Je suis désolé.
Attends. Allô
? OK. Sonic au secours ! Effectivement,
si Nintendo nous a donné sa soupe à la
merde, ces gars lui aussi a pissé dans
nos assiettes.
Les aventures de Sonic, certainement la
série la plus connue pour les gens de
mon âge parce que cette série existait
déjà quand moi-même j'étais au lycée.
Alors l'oping, avait beau être assez
catchi, pour autant je vais pas plus
parler de cette série qu'on a parlé de
la série Mario, simplement parce que
je suis prêt. Tu es prêt ? Je suis prêt.
Mais à quoi je suis prêt ? fait ton
tour.
Bah oui, cette série c'est juste un
condensé de tout ce qui était les
dessins animés de Bib ou de Buck Bunny.
Des méchants stupides qui essayent
d'attraper un truc qui court trop vite,
pas de continuité entre les épisodes et
surtout ça s'arrête jamais. Les gars
s'enchaînent en permanence sans jamais
s'arrêter. Cette série, on dirait une
espèce de bébé hyperactif qui va mourir
si elle ne s'arrête ne serait-ce qu'une
seconde de faire du
bruit. Les clés, les clés, il y a les
clés qui bougent, elles font du bruit.
Et ce machin, moi je me souviens que ça
passait à 7h30 le matin quand j'avais la
tête dans le cul. Ouais. Robotnic
faiton.
Bref, tout ça contraste énormément avec
la deuxième série de Sonic intitulée
Sonic le
une série franco-américaine qui a tenté
vraiment mais vraiment trop de rendre le
personnage de Sonic cool pour les
jeunes. Mais regardez [ __ ] il y a des
motos. Il fait de la guitare. Son frère
c'est un punk. Ça s'appelle Sonic le
rebelle. Il est cool. Il est cool.
Dites-moi qu'il est cool. Je me tue,
[ __ ] Et autant la première série
c'était l'absence totale de scénario et
de logique. Cette série là, c'est
l'inverse pur et simple. Beaucoup trop
de scénarios. Rien que le générique
t'explique absolument tout le scénar et
vas-y qu'il y a des prophéties et des
machins et des destinées et blabla et tu
sens que le mec il a pas le temps de
tout dire alors il trace.
W calme-toi. Tu expliques le scénario et
après tu chantes le générique. Je pas
mais comme ils font dans One Piece par
exemple, ça c'est bien mais fais pas les
deux en même temps. Et puis il y a la
fille qui veut devenir pirate il a un
chapeau de pike. Il a eu parce que Chan
s'est fait manger le bras alors il va se
gram pour lui rendre le chapeau One
Piece. Et puis je veux dire du calme là
c'est quoi cette avalanche de scénario ?
On parle juste hérisson qui court vite
et que c'est rigolo parce que
normalement les hérissons ça court pas
vite et qu'il est bleu. C'est tout.
C'est ça Sonic. Bref, la série prend
donc place sur la planète Mobus où on
retrouve la mère de Sonic, mère qui est
aussi la reine de la planète et qui au
passage ne s'est sûrement pas fait
tringler que par le roi vu que ses
enfants sont un peu de toutes les
couleurs. Mais un beau jour, Robotnic
prend le pouvoir. La reine réussit quand
même à s'échapper malgré tout avec ses
enfants et à vivre tranquillement
jusqu'au moment où un oracle dégueulasse
lui fait une prédiction.
Un jour, vous serez à nouveau réuni avec
vos enfants et vous formerez le conseil
des quatre. C'est vrai que je pourrais
me contenter de vivre tranquillement
avec mes enfants, mais franchement, si
c'est pour retrouver le
pouvoir, bref, pour retrouver le
pouvoir, elle abandonne donc ses trois
enfants auprès de trois familles
différentes. Sauf que un des enfants est
embarqué par un autre type dans la rue,
un méchant
kidnappeur qui l'élève correctement.
Ah, il y a rien de trop beau pour mon
petit
roi. Je vais lever cet enfant, lui payer
des études et lui donner plein d'amour.
Je suis démoniaque, monstre. Bref, les
trois enfants grandissent sans se poser
aucune question jusqu'au jour où
Robotnick retrouve les parents adoptifs
de Sonic qui doit donc s'enfuir. Va
aussi vite que tu peux chez ton oncle
Chuck. File droit devant toi sans te
retourner. Tu veux vraiment que je cave
? Ta gueule. Va [ __ ] ta mère. Sonic
s'enfuit et retrouve alors son oncle
mais restera quand même traumatisé à vie
par la mort de ses parents. No problème
tonton de choc.
Bref, alors que Sonic mène sa petite vie
tranquille de terroriste, l'oracle
revient pour lui dire qu'il est temps
d'accomplir sa destinée. Le temps est
venu, Sonic. Et au passage, c'est comme
pour Captaine N qui arrête le temps.
Pourquoi il peut pas le buter tout seul
Robotnic ? Non mais visiblement, il peut
faire apparaître ce qu'il veut. Il se
téléporte. On le voit même immobiliser
robotique en se téléportant directement
dans sa chambre. Je vais écraser tout le
monde, rouler sur les populations, broer
leurs petits enfants jusqu'au dernier.
[Musique]
Et à ce moment-là, vous vous dites
comment est-ce qu'on va passer d'un
dessin animé qui visiblement part dans
un délire combattant écolo qui se
battent contre une dictature tyrannique
? Ce qui finalement au passage est
exactement le scénario de l'autre série
Sonic Sonic et Sally à une série où il y
a trois hérissons qui jouent de la
guitare. Et bien il vous faudra chanter
la mélodie de votre cœur jeune et fier
hérisson. E w Voilà. Allez salut.
[Musique]
Il manque quelque
chose. Il y a un petit souci. Ouais la
logique.
Nous serons enfin réussi. Qu'est-ce
qu'ils foutent là ? Et pourquoi la voix
de Sonic, elle a changé ? Réun un jour.
Mais qu'est-ce que c'était que ça ?
Qu'est-ce que c'était que ça ? Qu'est-ce
que c'était que ça ? Bref, après ce
charmant et étrange interlut musical sur
lequel on va revenir plus tard, pendant
ce temps-là, les méchants essayent de
retrouver Sonic
grâce je je sais pas une base de données
d'anus d'animaux. Je sais pas ce qu'ils
font, ça me fatigue. Attends,
techniquement, vu que c'est aussi des
animaux là, ils sont pas en train de
matos là ? Regarde le petit cul du singe
et le petit cul bleu là. Maman mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites bande de gros
dégueulasse ? Donc évidemment les trois
hérisson qui étit dispersé dans une
ville énorme se retrouvent purement par
hasard dans le même bar. Tu permets que
je me mette à l'établi.
Non mais quel hasard ! On est au même
endroit au même moment et je sais
précisément jouer du seul instrument qui
était posé sur cette scène sans que
personne ne s'en serve. Et donc
maintenant, comme je disais, vous l'avez
compris hein, cette série ce n'est pas
qu'une simple série, c'est une série
remplie de super chansons, une par
épisode. Parce qu'évidemment quand tu es
fan des jeux Sonic, le premier truc que
tu te dis c'est [ __ ] ça serait bien
si chanté quand même. Donc on a par
exemple des chansons géniales comme
c'est méga cool d'être jeune.
C'est méga cool d'être jeune. Les
enfants peuvent faire un tas de trucs
marrants. Les grimaces sont français et
pasant jouer à chat au rebell à la
marelle manger des creries à la conne.
C'est méga cool
d'un cavaler partout.
Alors vous allez me dire mais comment
fini cette série ? Est-ce qu'ils vont
faire une musique si subversive que le
peuple va se rebeller contre le
dictateur ? Comment est-ce que la
musique peut vaincre une tyrannie ? Et
ben, elle peut pas, c'est ça le
problème. La série dure 40 épisodes avec
39 épisodes et demi de remplissage où il
aura que des aventures de merde qui
n'ont rien à voir avec le scénario. Et
finalement, dans les 20 dernières
secondes du dernier épisode, je ne
plaisante pas, ils prennent trois
vaisseaux bourrés d'explosifs et
collision imminente.
Ah ! Quand je pense qu'on s'est fait
chier à faire de la musique alors que
tout ce qu'il fallait faire c'était de
le faire péter avec une bombe. Alors
sans parler, je vous mentionne quand
même l'existence des autres séries
Sonic. On a par exemple Sonic et Sali où
il y a Sonic et puis sa copine furie de
la Japan Expo avec leurs potes chelous
qui combattent contre Robotnic et enfin
Sonic X et Sonic Boom qui sont deux
séries très différentes. Alors il y en a
une qui est sérieuse, l'autre qui est
plutôt comique et même si clairement la
série est de loin et je le reconnais la
mieux animée de toutes, j'ai
personnellement quand même un peu de mal
avec la multiplication des shitty
friends de Sonic qui sont arrivés avec
les Sonic Adventure. Et surtout vous
m'excusez mais Shadow c'est Vegeta. Tes
capacités sont tellement limitées que
cen est une honte pour la race des
hérissons. Alors, tu vas pas me dire que
Sonic c'était pas de la merde aussi ?
Ouais, OK. Mais j'ai un dernier argument
contre Nintendo. Ettant connaît dans les
chansons, est-ce que vous avez déjà
léché un urinoir sale sur une aire
d'autoroute, hein ? Et pas pas les aires
d'autoroute où il y a des magasins et
cetera, celle où il y a rien, vous voyez
? Ben, c'est encore je pense, une
expérience plus agréable que la série
qui va suivre. Don Kong country, une
série immonde en 3D et exclusivité
française. Et si ça vous parle, je pense
que c'est plus pour DK TV qui était
aussi animé par Don Ky Kong que pour la
série en elle-même qui était elle
surtout connue je pense pour ces super
chansons.
[Musique]
Et quel flow ! Après ne vous inquiétez
pas, il y a pas que le rap qui se soit
fait [ __ ] il y a plein d'autres
styles. Je voudrais comprendre ce qui se
passe.
On m'accuse de choses que je n'ai
pourtant pas fait. Qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ? C'est vrai, tu as raison. Il y
avait rien de bien. Voilà, c'est ça que
je voulais que tu comprennes. Bon, vous
allez me libérer les deux tarés. Et puis
vous êtes qui ? Qui ça ? nous
et connais-tu les deux frères les deux
frères greniers héros pas dans les jeux
vidéos bizarre bizarre tout paraît
bizarre chez les greniers toujours sur
les 8 bit à parler de jeux
rétro super grenier bros Yes.